[موسيقى]
من التلفاز إلى ألعاب الفيديو يقضي الأطفال
وقتًا طويلاً أمام
الشاشات ، حيث تُظهر أحدث الدراسات أن
متوسط ​​عمر الطفل من 8 إلى 18 عامًا يقضي
سبع ساعات ونصف الساعة
يوميًا في المشاركة في وقت الشاشة الذي
يعتمد على الترفيه أيضًا  الكثير من
الوقت الذي يقضيه أمام الشاشات يمكن أن يبتعد عن
النشاط البدني ، ويمكنه أيضًا فصل
الأطفال عن الآخرين.
عادات وقت الشاشة لعائلتك بمجرد معرفة
مقدار الوقت الذي يقضيه الآباء والأطفال على
الشاشات ، يقول بالمر إنه حدد أهدافًا واقعية
صغيرة وقلل وقت الشاشة
بزيادات ، حاول وضع الشاشات لمدة
10 دقائق إضافية كل يوم وزيادتها
بعد ذلك استبدل ذلك الوقت
بالعائلة  الوقت الذي يضع فيه هذه الحدود لا يعني
معاقبة أطفالنا أو أن يكون
له عواقب سلبية ، ولكنه حقًا
لحمايتهم ، يقول بالمر لإعداد
الشاشة-  تقوم المناطق الحرة بإزالة الأجهزة أثناء
أوقات الوجبات ومن غرفة النوم يمكن أن
تبقي الطفل مستيقظًا طوال الليل سواء
كان يتلقى تنبيهات على هواتفهم
وقد ثبت أن الضوء وحده من
الأجهزة
يقلل من جودة النوم
للبالغين والأطفال  المفتاح الذي تقوله
هو أن يتبع الكبار نفس القواعد
التي
يضعونها لأطفالهم في الدقيقة الصحية ، أنا ماندي غايثر